here we've gone over the hill
hello
a method for your Diego Thank You Felicia
military captured a Yankee stealing firearms
is we tried this morning by the console they
want to say who is he Kayla Kayla why
he's narrator Terry leader of the tribe
very popular with the Aggies but that trial
will be a farce any way down to Laurel uses
influence of the counselors to free Kayla
Brett you're right so it may help us to
uncover down the law the counselors who
plead for a light or suspended sentence
will be the ones connected with down the law
if we follow them they may leave this to him
case of the state versus Kayla a Yacky charged
with violating statute 419 of the Civil Code
specifically stealing firearms there's a filing
number of Indians defying this law so presents a
grave situation especially as the yaki seemed
to be completely under the influence of Don
dolor I strongly recommend the full penalty of
the law be imposed in this case but the penalty
calls for only 30 days imprisonment so lighter
sentence will never stop the Yankees for bombing
themselves what do you recommend that we enact
a new penalty imposing the death sentence all
violators of this law but gentlemen kayla is the
Prince of the yaki tribes greatly beloved by his
people twice security so slight an offense would
make the Indians like us even less than they do
now we want their obedience not their affection I
propose that Kayla be hanged in the public square
tomorrow morning excellent make an example of
it I also agree show the yaki they cannot break
our laws and live and we'll have little to fear
from that Porter except bloodshed and death so
Kayla's execution will saw round the Yaquis that
they were storming overruns and Mendeley - in
their fury this hanging must be prevented at all
cause but it's a task for only a few others much
depends upon the rescue of Kayla if we fail
the Yankees will engage in a war of revenge
with Don DeLauro as their leader I want for
volunteers to help rescue Kayla we'll draw for it
all right make an air this bad
horrible isn't it dangerous
come about quick we are your friends
this is summit sorro's work
gerrae but bu I would have died Kayla's life
belongs to his white product then listen kid
listen to your blood brother kayla listens
thunder Laura wanted you to die so that he
could lead your people on a war of revenge leave
them to death and ruin no Don DeLauro takes care
of his children then why did he leave you
to be hanged your brother knows that the
God you worship has been defiled by a white
man think now for many years your God slept
then suddenly he rose walked and spoke his words
edge your people to forget the years they lived
in peace with her white brothers into war upon
those words were not the wish of your true God
but came for the white man who had stolen
into Don Delores body you must save your
people from death and destruction let me expose
this false God take me with you to Don the law
I will take my brother to down
tomorrow good but no one else if
you are wrong don davara will kill you
don't go the risk is too great no risk
is too great if it's taken for mexico
ride to san manolito and wait for me
dan tomorrow's cave is beyond that rock good
see it's empty
come see for yourself
you all right yeah quick it
you must come in your people
many of the tribes listen to Kayla
sorrow has proven to me that don
DeLauro is a false god wait with my own
eyes I have seen the shell of gold Don
De La Rose body empty and helpless
even now it rests in the cave come
see for yourself where we go why do you
spit with a crooked tongue you will die
see there's nothing to fear
there the unbeliever